you are both here today to be sentenced
having been convicted by the jury on the
6th of March of the murder of 16 year
old rishmeet Singh you may remain seated
until I tell you to stand up
you Mr balakrishnan are also here for an
offense of causing Grievous bodily harm
with intent contrary to section 18 of
the offenses against the person act
which was committed by you on the 1st of
July of 2022 while you were on remand at
Felton young offender Institution
I need to call that the section 18
offense
you pleaded guilty to that offense on
the 10th of March of this year
this case is yet another
tragic example of the needless loss of a
young teenager's life
following a violent stabbing on the
Streets of London
this case is the more tragic because
Rish meat was an entirely innocent
victim
at your trial all who knew Rish meat
spoke very fondly of him
he was described by friends as a good
person who would not harm a fly
as pure of heart and a humble guy
he wouldn't get into a beef with anyone
he was never involved in any kind of
violence he had no convictions or
cautions he did not drink alcohol or
take drugs
and it defies belief that you too sought
him out to kill him
the impact of his death at your hands
cannot be overstated
in her victim personal statement his
mother Mrs core tells a heart-rending
story
in 2019 she came to the UK with her
mother and her only child wish meet as
Asylum Seekers from Afghanistan
rashmeet's father had been killed by the
Taliban
Taliban had tried to kidnap Richmond and
convert him to Islam
as seeks the local gadwara helped them
Escape
they came here to seek a safe life
neither She nor her mother speak good
English
they were Reliant upon Rich meat for
communication
rishmeet was his mother's carer as she
is disabled by polio
they moved to Southall to be closer to
an afghan-seek community
with hindsight that decision to move
will haunt Rish meat's mother and
grandmother for the rest of their lives
with Rich meat's help they obtained a
flat he was a vital and invaluable
conduit in all administrative tasks
Rish Meats showed all the signs of
growing into a valued member of society
he hoped to become a police officer
against that background with hope for a
peaceful future and a productive and
rewarding life for her son Mrs Carr
describes her loss following her son's
murder
she cannot put into words the impact
upon herself and Rich meets grandmother
she says I have lost everything and my
life is over
I will never get over losing him in this
way
she will not see him grow up and fulfill
his aspirations
he had his whole future ahead of him
his mother now feels lonely and isolated
16 months since Rish meets death and her
Palin has not subsided
she's on medication for depression her
mother too is devastated at the loss of
her grandson
your actions have left those two women
entirely bereft
with no male figure in their lives in a
country where they don't speak the
language a country where they sought
Refuge from a violent regime only to
face the ultimate loss as a result of
what you two did
nothing I can do or say today can bring
Rich meat back or relieve the pain your
actions have caused
no term of years will be sufficient
punishment so far as his father his
mother and grandmother are concerned
no term of years can even begin to
compensate then
you two are very close friends
you were both 17 in November 2021 when
you committed the murder
from about September 2020 you Mr
balakrishnan started hanging around in
Hayes and there you met older Haze Town
Gang members and quickly became involved
in the gang culture
you saw their expensive clothes and
their postings of gang signs and you
were attracted by the scene
you were initially sucked in by the
offer of free cannabis but you ran up
debts and were forced to deal class A
drugs as a result
it is an all too familiar picture in
this court
a safe house at 68 Austin Road was used
as a base by the gang to store drugs and
weapons
on the 21st of January of 2021 you Mr
balakrishman was stopped by police and
found to be in possession of a lethal
knife
you received a referral order and were
allocated a social worker who taught you
the dangers of knife crime
on the 11th of June of the same year you
were stopped by police and found in
possession of heroin crack cocaine cash
and two phones
by then you were involved in the regular
drug dealing for which you were paid
considerable sums of money
you Mr Solomon got to know gang members
through Mr balakrishnan you have no
previous convictions and people who know
you speak very highly of you
however you two were given cannabis and
became a regular user
I am of the firm view that by the time
of the murder you too were an
enthusiastic gam member who was willing
to join in with the nefarious activities
of the haze Town Gang
I note that your half-sister confirms my
view
the two of you would go to the Austin
Road estate every day where you'd hang
out with other gang members and smoke
cannabis
on the 19th of November 2021 you Mr
balakrishnan purchased a large
rambo-style machete from the internet
sites with which this court is very
familiar and from which such knives for
which there is no legitimate use can be
bought with impunity
the knife you bought was similar to the
one which the police had taken from you
early in the earlier in the year
the 24th of November 2021 was the day of
the murder
rishmeet Singh was socializing with his
friends they were not drinking alcohol
or taking drugs he was not armed
CCTV showed the two of you leaving 68
Austin Road at 8 47 p.m having changed
from the clothes that you were wearing
earlier
you Mr Solomon had a particularly large
three foot long machete style knife
concealed in your tracksuit trousers
you Mr balakrishnan either took the
knife which you had purchased with you
from with you from since number 68 or
you collected it from a stash by the
canal on route to the Rival territory
you were each riding a bicycle
you identified Rish meat and his friends
as potential targets and he began to
chase them
by chance a BMW was in the area which
may well have contained gang Rivals and
interaction between you and the
occupants of that car may have led you
wrongly to associate Rich meat and his
friends with a Southall gang
the two of you approached Richmond's
group in a threatening manner
his friends were able to escape but
rishmeet ran off on his own and when he
tripped over the CCTV showed that the
two of you ferociously attacked him each
of you stabbing him repeatedly with
those lethal knives you Mr balakrishnan
made five separate stabbing movements
you Mr Solomon of further ten
as Rich meat Lay Dying in a doorway you
headed off collected the bikes and rode
back to number 68. there you changed
your clothes and went to your respective
homes by taxi
you both went back to number 68 the
following day and arranged for the bikes
and your blood-stained clothing to be
disposed of
at the scene where rich meat was to die
the Emergency Services have been called
at seven minutes past nine
he had suffered multiple sharp force
injuries to his head and chest and
penetrating injuries to his brain liver
and lung they were through and through
injuries to his arm which were
consistent with defensive injuries as he
held his arms up to try to protect
himself
there are at least 11 and up to 15
separate stab wounds
despite the efforts of the Medics his
injuries were not survivable and he died
at the scene
the very same night you Mr balakrishnan
having taken your blood-stained knife
back to your bedroom photographed it and
posted a photograph on social media
you then wrote drill lyrics glorifying
The Killing which included lines such as
one tripped and fell and he knew it was
over I was swinging my Shank
swinging my blade back and forth trying
to turn him off
he tripped and got dipped onto my Shank
chasing him with a nank really trying to
open his chest apart trying to push my
knife through his lungs
those chilling lyrics were found in the
very notebook in which you had recorded
the lessons you'd learned about the
dangers of knife crime as part of your
referral order
you were arrested at your home on the
2nd of December of 2021 you did not
answer police questions
you Mr Solomon ran away from your home
when you heard about Mr balakrishnan's
arrest your mother reported you missing
you were arrested at a cousin's address
on the 8th of December you admit that
you were planning to leave the country
you also did not answer police questions
you were both remarked into custody and
you Mr balakrishna were held at feltham
young offender Institution
the second serious offensive violence
for which I have to deal with you took
place on the 1st of July 2022
that was when you were still on remand
for the murder at Felton
you and four other inmates including
Marcus Walker who I sentenced yesterday
were in the exercise yard at around 10
30 in the morning
there is poor quality footage of the
incident
however several prison officers were
able to describe what took place
what
intervene even after that the attack
continued
during the attack Walker Was Heard to
shout finish him off and this is how you
put man's to sleep
Walker also said I had to start it
that's what you get to which you
responded repeatedly rest in peace
the two of you were laughing
the motive for that attack was Revenge
ful unconscious when he briefly regained
Consciousness he begged the officers to
save his life saying I have a daughter
he then fell back into unconsciousness
he was taken to hospital by air
ambulance he had suffered increased
pressure and bleeding to his brain which
was life-threatening
he underwent lengthy surgery but is left
with permanent and significant brain
damage
cognitive functions are badly affected
and he will require lengthy
Rehabilitation and ongoing long-term
input from multidisciplinary teams in
order to support him in reaching his
full potential
I then turned to the approach to
sentence
in relation to the murder
you are both now 18 you were both 17 at
the date of the murder
as you both know the sentence for murder
is fixed by law and I must pass a life
sentence upon you both
due to the fact that you were under 18
when the murder was committed the
sentence is one of detention at his
Majesty's pleasure
I have to set the minimum term that you
must each served before you can be
considered for release by the parole
board
I begin by identifying the appropriate
starting point under paragraph 5A of
schedule 21 of the sentencing act 2020
as amended by section 127 of the peace
crime and sentencing and courts act 2022
because you each took a knife to the
scene and had it with you intending to
use it as you in fact did the starting
point is now one of 23 years
I observe that the starting point for a
16 year old is six years lower namely 17
years that was in fact the starting
point I took in the case of Walker who I
sentenced for a different murder
yesterday
the aggravating factors are these one in
your case Mr balakrishna and your
previous conviction for possession of a
knife
two in both your cases that you planned
the offense you changed your clothing
disguised your faces and traveled to
rival gang territory with the sole
purpose of attacking members of a rival
gang you Mr balakrishnan put your phone
onto flight mode and you Mr Solomon gave
your phone to another gang member so
that it could be used to lay a false
Trail
three this was Gang Related defending
four you both took steps to avoid being
connected to the murder
you disposed of your clothing and
arranged for the bicycles to be
discarded
five you Mr balakrishnan posted that
picture of one of the murder weapons
onto social media and glorified your
actions in sickening drill lyrics
finally you Mr Solomon got rid of your
phone went to ground and planned to flee
the country you also changed your
appearance
turning to mitigation
in your case Mr balakrishna and having
heard you give evidence and read reports
upon you I regard the following as
mitigating factors one your immaturity
whilst your chronological age is
reflected in the reduction of the
starting point from for the minimum term
from 25 years for an adult down to 23
years I also need to consider the case
law which emphasizes that a person's
actual maturity may be different from
that to be expected at their age
you are described in reports as young
for your age you have limited
intellectual functioning and emotional
intelligence
secondly you have been found to have
been a victim of modern slavery
thirdly you have a lack of formal
positive structure or role models in
your life and fourthly you are
susceptible to pressure from others your
psychological profile suggested that you
took a notably passive role in
relationships and depended on others for
guidance
and you have reduced intellectual
functioning
in your case Mr Suleiman whilst there
are no reports I heard you give evidence
also and I have read the numerous
testimonials
I take the following factors into
account in your favor your lack of
convictions your immaturity and
susceptibility to pressure as a result
of wanting to fit in
thirdly the lack of a stable home
structure at a crucial time in your life
and fourthly the obviously positive
character traits described by the
character Witnesses
none who know you can believe that
you've got yourself involved in this
most serious offense
the complementary adjectives used to
describe the young man who those people
describe are all totally opposite of the
young man who made the decision to go
out with a huge knife and inflict misery
upon others by killing a 16 year old
child
sadly you threw away all that good
when you made that decision
I note the realistic assessment by your
older sister who observed a
deterioration and a change in you she
saw you getting embroiled into the gang
culture and running drugs for the gang
leaders for about four months prior to
the murder
balancing the aggravating and mitigating
factors in each of your cases I see no
reason to make any distinction between
the two of you in relation to the murder
having balanced the competing factors I
have come to the conclusion that the
appropriate minimum term in each of your
cases for the murder is 21 years
in your case Mr balakrishnan the minimum
term must be increased to reflect the
section 18 offense
the group attack upon a fellow inmate
involves significant planning it was a
Revenge attack upon a youth who your
group perceived to be a snitch
the victim suffered particularly grave
and life-threatening injury
that offense fell within category 1A of
the relevant guideline with a starting
point for an adult of 12 years and a
range of 10 to 16 years
there are a number of aggravating
factors
one the fact that this was an attack
within a custodial setting to the fact
that you were on remand having pleaded
not guilty to rishmead's murder and
three your previous conviction
the mitigating factors are those which I
have set out above in relation to the
murder I do not repeat them
in relation to this offense the
mitigating factors balance out the
aggravating factors
I emphasize that I have guarded against
any double counting and born firmly in
mind the youth guideline the guideline
relating to mentally disordered
offenders and totality
you were days away from your 18th
birthday when you committed that section
18 offense however your role in the
offense was slightly less significant
than that of Walker and accordingly the
same sentence is merited as that which I
identified in his case that is a
sentence before plea of eight years
detention
you were originally charged with
attempted murder to which you pleaded
not guilty you entered a plea to the
section 18 offense on the 10th of March
of 2023 your trial had been listed for
July of this year
you deserve 25 credit for your plea
which gives a term of six years
whilst the sentence for the section 18
will be imposed concurrently that
offense will be reflected as I have said
in the increased minimum term attached
to the murder sentence
I then have to consider dangerousness
in your case I am of the firm view that
despite your Youth and the other matters
to which I have referred on all the
facts of this case you do present a
significant risk of serious harm to the
public occasioned by the commission by
you of further specified offenses the
author of the pre-sentence report is of
the same view
in my judgment acknowledging that a life
sentence is a last resort the section 18
offense is in itself serious enough to
justify a life sentence and there is no
real reliable estimate of the length of
time you will remain a danger in any
event of course you will be serving the
life sentence which I'm about to impose
for the murder of Rish meat
would you both stand up please
the sentences I pass upon you are as
follows for the murder detention at his
Majesty's pleasure with a minimum term
of 24 years
from section 18 detention at his
Majesty's pleasure for a minute with a
minimum term of four years that's
two-thirds of the notional determinant
term
you have spent 524 days in detention on
remand which will count towards your
sentence so the minimum term is 24 years
less 524 days
Ilia Suleiman the sentence I pass upon
you for the murder is detention at his
Majesty's pleasure with a minimum term
of 21 years
you have spent 517 days in detention on
demand which will count towards your
sentence and so the minimum term is 21
years less 517 days
if the information which I've been
provided with as today's in detention on
demand proves to be inaccurate then the
prosecution or defense must notify the
court so that the case can be re-listed
to correct the calculation as soon as
possible and in any event within 56 days
of today
you must both understand and all those
who are listening must understand that
you will not be released when you have
served those minimum terms you indeed
you will only be released if and when
the parole board conclude that either or
both of you no longer pose a risk of
harm to the public and that will not be
until you have served at least every day
of the minimum terms which I have just
imposed
that's the sentence of the Court they
may go down thank you